so today we have a very special guest in
studio you guys know him as the
Internet's boyfriend Noah Santa nail is
in Netflix's new film to all the boys
I've loved before he's in Sierra Burgas
I mean you've known him from the Fosters
for a while so we're just so blessed
we're bowing down to Noah for this
interview I am blessed to be here right
now you are just so charming and I
remember when we first talked in the
interview like you just have this spirit
about you and I love that the Internet
feels the same way so just like these
love letters are out now your movies are
out how are you reacting to being the
newest heartthrob oh god I just hang it
out you know and I hope I hope not a lot
does change I'll say the same thing I
kind of said before an anticipation was
like the outer world is gonna change for
sure and like whether it's more people
knowing who I am or more jobs coming in
but like I want my inner space to stay
the same right and that's really
important to me I mean with all this
buzz it's it sounds like you're a little
bit of a private person like you love to
have like that family time and whatnot
would you say that about yourself yeah
yeah so this like when people are in
your diems and are sending you all these
wild tweets I mean do you ignore them
are you responding what's like your your
thing to say ground it most part I I
kind of just don't even really look at
it if I actually found myself engaging
with like people I've looked up to for
years on like Twitter though yeah
there's this artist called Quinn ex-cia
and I've been like listening to his
music for a really really long time and
I forget how but like we got in contact
on Twitter because I think I like shared
one of his instagrams or no that was a I
put his song on my Instagram story and
he hit me up it was like yo thanks for
the love and I was like yo thanks for
your music Wow a big fan I am and like
his music is like really like I I really
relate to it and that's been really
really cool just being able to talk to
people that I look up to exactly and I'm
sure that's gonna keep rolling in
because I've seen both films and they
are incredible but it seems like you are
now the guy that everyone goes to we
rom-coms it's like Noah and rom-coms are
a thing
no I do not yet that'd be cool uh okay
well since everyone right now is buzzing
over your rom-coms I want to know what
you ever want to play a villain have you
ever thought of something like that yeah
absolutely I'd love to turn around and
do something else I think that there's
like really healthy ways to check I just
did a hair flip I haven't done a hair
flip since I was like 15 we shaggy I was
always like I had the Bieber like bull
cut like remember the idea everyone call
to the Bieber
always doing that anyway well now it's a
Noah it's a little bit of a tangent but
I think there's a good way to segue into
different roles in different genres I'm
not opposed to shaving my head and like
doing something crazy we just talked
about your signature hair and you're
gonna shave it off Noah don't do that
too advanced I want to talk about some
things that director Susan Johnson has
said about you she has she spilled so
much tea on to all the boys I've loved
before I want to get your take on some
things that she addressed with us so
we're swooning over Peter and Laura Jean
and we see this lockscreen photo now she
tells us that this was something they
took in between takes how do you fall
asleep with your co-star like that it's
like long hours on set I'm pretty sure
that was in the middle of night shoots
and it's like not uncommon for like all
of us to just like cuddle with each
other like Israel and I cuddled together
like it's like not uncommon and so I was
like just laying there cuz I I sleep a
lot like what I think one of the times a
lot of just like there's like I'll sleep
with you I was like all right cause she
like cuddle didn't really did you ever
feel the cameras on you guys cuz it
looked like a deep sleep from the lock
photo I'll remember the photo being
taken so yeah another thing she said
which I I agree with it since I've met
both of you guys she said that you are a
natural flirt and that Lana is a
hopeless romantic now do you feel like
that's why your chemistry is so strong I
think that that goes both ways for both
of us it's not just like I'm the flirt
she's the romantic
the flare emits all of it I would say
it's it's a little bit to do with one
how amazing the noxious she is that's
like a really big part of it and it's
just really easy to react and listen to
her when she she's acting because she's
so natural and then another part of it
just has to do with the fact that like I
think we have similar perspectives on
life our outlooks are similar and and we
just like really like to talk and
communicate and we got to know each
other really well so that that made it
really easy
Wow sounds like some deep conversations
well life and oh I'd love to be a fly on
the wall especially with Israel man that
kid operates from a place of love so
like having him on set like like all of
us like it's just like a really deep
conversation all the time okay so with
that you know the Internet has been
shipping you guys for so long have you
talked about making a marriage pact if
we are both single will we get together
Ilana she's come down the line I mean
you make those with your best friends
yeah oh yeah I made that was my boy
Aaron like I got that with my buddy AVI
odd like it's a hundred percent of thing
I haven't made it with Lana though okay
well Internet not not yet not yet yeah
have you gone on any double dates with
her and her boyfriends oh no no no well
anyways let's go ahead and move on cuz
you are in so many things right now but
the one that everyone is anticipating is
Sierra Burgas and I love this film I
mean everyone loves Peter but Jamie is
my guy so I got enough I need to know
are you more of a Peter or a Jamie and
realize like most of the time that's
like for sure right but like if if I'm
in an environment or circumstance that
calls for like a Peter like ego
aggressive mentality to come out than
lakeshore but like in my day to day for
most of the time I I stick to I stick to
Jamie okay so they say Jamie's kind of
like dorky and charming so you'd be you
considered absolutely thank you he is
goofy yeah he's got is like dope friends
too and they're like super
I like him right I think yeah I like
Jamie I love Peter Peters Peters fuse my
man but I'm more like I'm more like
changing almost the time I like both
characters so either one you can't go
wrong right right yes so we also heard
that there you know there's like two
books for to all the boys I've loved
before three books and Susan already
told us that a sequel is very likely and
she said the storyline between Peter and
Laura Jean would be that you guys would
have some struggles you're kind of out
of the honeymoon phase how would you
like to see Peter develop your character
how do you like that to develop well
truthfully don't really matter what I
think about it it's already written but
that sounds good like I feel like that's
very true in real in relationships you
you get together and it's it's really
like fresh and new and and wonderful and
then you start to realize the inner the
inner mechanics of like either living
with a person or being with someone on
day to day basically basis or a weekly
basis and and the struggles that come
with that are sick I'd like to see that
come with with Peter Kate's here now
listen I mean it seems like you're
speaking from experience how do you
relate to Peter in real life as far as
relationships and dating something
that's similar about Peter and eyes is
him with his ex-girlfriend right he felt
like as far as like going back into her
room and and and like being kind of led
by her with that bathroom scene when he
lets her take the the scrunchie I can
understand the concept of of still
letting someone else have power over you
if you've like loved them before and
that's definitely like it and it's just
a dynamic to play with outside of that
Peter's crazy and like he's wild and he
likes to have a good time and I'm pretty
same way okay I love that you like to
have a good time okay like why else are
we here right exactly it's speaking of
good time we want to have a good time
with you we have a couple games we want
to play are you down okay so we first I
want to play a game with you based off
of some romantic tweets that you have
actually sent out okay
okay so Dooney come on oh okay okay okay
yes
so we'll set this up for you Noah is
gonna go ahead and read some of his most
romantic tweets but there's a little bit
of a twist I want you to say it in your
sweetest most romantic voice you got it
give me some of that acting please and
direct this one straight to your family
this romantically say this as this is
like really like a meat thing is like
hard to be romantic about all right
you wrote this no I'm so bad at like
doing this like doing like the romantic
stuff like like reading my stuff like
her anyway okay yeah sometimes when I'm
feeling lonely I take myself out to
dinner a crowded restaurant you ever
done that you ever gone to like sweet
green you ever gone the sweet green and
just sat at a table by yourself and
eating food it's nice it feels good you
kind of reach that your recharges you
put your phone down you focus on anyway
next one this is I stole this from
there's this place called superba on
Rose I've it's closed now is in Venice
California and they had this sign right
above it and it says she's both
beautiful and terrifying at the same
time like nature itself the lip bite at
the end I think about it do you remember
how fun and intimately intricate making
out can be like that's the best thing
sometimes it's good no it's so good
please it's hard to take it seriously
when I'm reading it back like in the
moment I'm like oh this is how I feel
I'm so passionate like now I'm like yes
I felt that way don't make me feel that
way again oh love deeply break your
heart love deeper and repeat which is
one of the morals and all the boys
actually you got to tell people how you
feel when you feel it this is one of my
favorite reads of all times to the girl
and the high-waisted denim shorts dark
spaghetti strapp t-shirt and red clip in
her hair who I haven't stopped thinking
about since earlier today when I didn't
even attempt to talk to you as you
walked past me I'm still thinking about
you and it's heartbreaking and the
Thermage is
are we in your monologue clarify that
with you it's real like swimming so I
went to New York and I was meeting with
a magazine editor and I'm in I'm in the
car and like rolling up to the the place
I'm really close to where I have to get
out of the car and I see this girl like
crossing the crosswalk wearing like
those denim denim and a spaghetti strap
in this red clip and I was kind of just
taken at like how she was just walking
with purpose and like she was like
gorgeous from like a block and a half
away and I was like I will I'm gonna car
there's an you know whatever that's cool
so we pull up to the building and I
literally I like open the door to get
out of car and as I stand up she passes
me fate and he's like walking away from
me and I'm like and I'm like walking
like six feet behind her just like
thinking myself oh my god it's her and
like you know like yeah this is like I
should say something and I I usually do
why I'm usually the person that's like
oh I feel something I'm gonna do it and
I did it and so then she's just like I
like she went I walked into the building
and I was like heartbroken that I didn't
say anything and watch that's gonna be
your wife you're gonna find her in a few
years there's gonna be a full-circle
moment and she's gonna be like I
remember you - it was May 21st 2018 at
1:24 p.m. so it was like midday when I
saw you and yeah you can't remember what
you and you probably won't wow us all
right
fans are gonna go in they're gonna tell
you that they they were the girl I'd be
ready for your deems to be crazy
I was this is an example when I'm a
hopeful romantic cuz I was coming out
the meeting like I'll bet you she'll be
on her way home when I come out at the
right time like it's gonna work okay
okay don't I got a story
don't I get a story don't look at a
story don't don't just don't look any
stories don't look at it maybe just once
that's fine
who's gay and you looked at her story
thank you for putting me through that
you are made for rom-coms so the fun
doesn't end I actually have one more
round oh yeah I'm here for the long haul
okay cool so we have an ET Fast Five
that we do with our guests so I want to
get your take on these
first response let's go okay boxers or
briefs please would you ever date a fan
well no but but here's it depends like
probably not no it's not like I refuse
to close any door completely but
probably not got it
now when it comes to cuddling are you
the big spoon or the little spoon I
could be both how is that possible
different in different settings
different sessions oh yeah not at the
same time okay that's kind of difficult
you just figure out what day I want to
be the guys like probably like in the
beginning of the relationship I'll be
like the big spoon but then like a few
months and I'll be like hey like can you
like can you like hold me please
know what I like being out sometimes
okay okay so judge me speaking of that
we're Netflix and chilling it what's
your favorite rom-com to watch I just I
just watched serendipity okay but it's
not enough that's your jam all right
well what's the most romantic thing
someone has ever done for you oh my
heart is very romantic it's hard to
steal heart write that do something on
that anyway no I guess there was so
Valentine's Day a little bit ago this
girl I was with took me on a scavenger
hunt hmm leaving me clues going to the
place we first met like the exact
ping-pong table that we first met and
then to the place that we first like
really had a conversation and then the
place was like our first date and then
like all through that like these
different places and my friends were all
involved and ultimately ended at the
place that I lived in like she liked
granite and surprised me with what
someone did this for you it was
incredible I want to talk to you about
your foster's days so obviously that was
a period of your life but now the
fosters are having a spinoff so you're
gonna be on is it two episodes what
episode on that on the first season okay
so tell us how you're gonna come back
into play in the spin-off I come back
into play on this panel Wow
you need to tease something no okay well
I don't watch it because it's that good
dope like that is my character in it
which is really funny like how they how
they bring him back but more so like I
saw the second episode hmm we call them
human shoes at lunch like sometimes I'll
show an episode and the show is shot
like differently than the Fosters III
love the way that they're they're
they're one like tying in different
angles and editing it together
the the content on the show like what
they're writing about is different and
and I has it as a 22 year old like I
relate to the show a lot and it was
really really really cool to see it and
I was shot is doing more than one
episode that's pretty cool but it had to
be awesome to reunite with your sisters
on screen what was that like it was meh
it was like be at home they be at home
for Christmas or Thanksgiving oh well I
can't wait for us to see that so we can
know a little bit more but you have so
much going on another project that
you're working on the director and the
writer is Jackie Chan how do you what is
it like working with a legend like that
are you kicking butt in this one or are
you a romantic tell us what we're in for
so first and foremost that man is so
driven so talented and so kind like
incredible stealing from Kanye that
guy's got dragon energy like like
incredible and it's a his first auteur
arthouse film so it's not like action
based it's a drama and it's it's really
it's a serious film a little bit of
comedy my character brings some comedy
but also some heartbreaking moments as
well I don't know how much I can tell
you and I that but it was an honor to be
able to go to China to meet him and his
son and to be a part of a film like that
and it's a Chinese language film okay so
you actually had to know me okay but a
lot of 90% 95% of film I believe is in
Chinese Wow
yeah might not even I don't even know if
it's coming out in America well I want
to see it so I hope it comes out in
America me too
I want to touch on something that you
did in Sierre Burgas you're a brother in
the film does sign language did you have
yeah did you have to learn the any
American sign language before often very
a little bit I did trained a little bit
too like this is my brother I know how
to spell my name my brother's name I
don't really like it's very specific
yeah and I did not learn how to speak it
how to sign it at all but it definitely
opened my eyes to the community you know
they're they're very loving like when
when a kid who signs is saying his name
the way they spell their name is you can
equate it to our inflection and like
emotion and saying our names so when the
way they sign their name shows their
personality okay like is like it'd be
like me trying to define myself by how I
say my name right like has a little swag
on it swag whatever it is yeah it's
tight it's really beautiful community so
apparently your creator of a lot of
things okay so the game is called can
you believe Noah invent it and I'm gonna
tell you some of the things that they
say you've invented what do y'all saying
about me a visit huh so can you believe
Noah invented floral shirts yeah you
rock one pretty well whole thing right
another one can you believe Noah I've
never heard of it
can you believe Noah invented being
sentimental they gave you a lot Noah I'm
like super sentimental I believe that
one okay you never meant to when's the
last time you cried during a movie a
movie mm-hmm like a week ago which one
what was it I was watching it with I
can't remember it it's okay I was
watching it with my friend and she
started crying and then like I looked at
her she looked at me and I had tears
welling up and she was like it was
you're fine who held who after that cry
though it was like it's fine
can you believe and Noah invented
looking good in Polaroids right no no
okay I wish all right can you believe
Noah invented the word meditate no way
yep they say you invented it so how do
you balance your life send the record
straight
thank you brand invented meditation
everybody knows that okay so guys no he
didn't invent that one but he's he's
pretty good at it apparently can you
believe that noah invented heart eyes
that's the illusion i thought it would
have been like that the like one herself
no screengrab i just saw it is that what
that is
[Laughter]
you are walking emoji i love it all
right can you believe that noah invented
boyfriend material
no why do you say that I'm not boyfriend
material how are you not I got lolly
dude
okay so top three things that make
someone girlfriend material really good
at communicating so communicating
effectively being present like in the
moment and you know whether that's like
when we're together we're together and
someone who's dedicated to herself
really good solid stuff last one and I
know this one is true can you believe
Noah invented smiling I would say you're
pretty good at it now think about it
this is bad
stop they love you know why they love
you and we love you thank you so much
for stopping in and talking to us about
all things going on with you were so
proud of you thank you so much I really
appreciate all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]